to tell you who won exactly sir price of
8 out of 11 and well I have to hand it
to magnet he makes it look so
effortlessly just to correct I know that
Magnus had a lot of what okay I wanted
to say his highest rated fidei was 2882
I'm alive
he was like 28 89 right that I think he
is now at this moment above 2882 I would
guess right back to you on that Yasser
gave me just the same it's it's not 2900
which we all want y'all want to see of
course that would be quite a record but
here is our winner 20 crown Chester
points $90,000 the richer and well eight
points out of 11 he is going to be as
the English say chuffed to bits
yes he is and with good reason because
Magnus is rewriting the record books he
is doing personal best undefeated and
gosh knows maybe 78 games in a row or
something like this who's gonna stop
this and he'll be tying his personal
record
he's currently at twenty eight eighty
one point seven be there rounds up and
he's not playing any more tournaments
that are classically rated he is playing
blades of rapid I believe until next
month and that's when the new list comes
out so speaking of the man of the hour
we have Maurice Ashley with world
champion and Croatia Grantchester winner
Magnus Carlsen
we're with the world champion Magnus
Carlsen after an 8th straight victory
victory here in Croatia
Magnus let's talk about this game you
spent a little bit of time somewhere
around here Bishop d3 maybe Bishop g4
what was your reason for pause I mean
basically there are several possible and
most there's moves there and I wasn't
really sure which one to choose so but I
was anyway happy to get this kind of
position it's it's definitely not
for for white but I thought with a
tournament situation there would be
little risk so that's good and maybe
some some chances to play as well your
mindset as you said the tournament
situation what was it going into the
game oh I thought I'll try and play a
little bit of this not with too much
risk but at least this Ryan I guess what
happened in the game was pretty ideal
what do you think he did wrong here
you said it doesn't seem like it's too
much but so at some point you just seem
like a disaster yeah I think Bishop
takes f3 is extremely risky so I think
when you give up the bishop like this
you really need you really need to have
a good plan otherwise it's it's going to
be very very dangerous and I'm not sure
if I play the best way afterwards but
it's always going to be unpleasant and
completely risk-free for for whites so I
was very happy to to see that move that
was that was for sure his position
collapsed it's at some point when you
you got the bishop to a6 and yeah I
thought I thought I'd hear where he was
gonna try a knight c6 but I mean the
position is still very unpleasant for
him but and here as well I thought GF I
was going to be the move and moves like
h4 f5 and so on it's a huge advantage
for for white but maybe there are some
some drawing chances but well in the
game I think there are very few chances
friend you've now won seven tournaments
in a row this year one also from last
year you picked up in the world
championship the train just seems to be
rolling amongst if I dare say smoothly
along the track I think this in this
tournament I had a bit of a rough patch
if I may call it that in the in the
first half but it seems to be the trend
in every tournament right now that I or
almost every tournament that
fight really hard in in the first half
and I'm really tired before the free day
but then when I get that free day and at
rest I usually pick it up in the in the
second half so but I mean it's certainly
one of I mean I've never scored anything
like +5 against such a field before so
it's yeah it's it's it's very well you
said never scored +5 no I don't think I
don't think I have I mean I've scored +5
in other tournaments but nuts in one
word there are just no Outsiders
whatsoever just all top players so
that's I mean what can I say it's it's
fun to play it's fun to watch pretty
impressive congratulations on being the
winner thank you
Magnus Carlsen the champion of the
Croatian Grantchester quick question for
Magnus about the time control please
think we lost it again
Magnus how do you like the new time
control the time control gasser with a
question did the time control affect you
in any way do you like the time control
yeah I like it when it's when it's a bit
faster than the normal one and in this
case we have so much time to have to
spend in the early stages anyway so I
don't think it takes to too much away so
yeah I'm all first right seal of
approval from the world champion that's
what we wanted to hear thank you so very
much our tournament standings yes and
that victory has propelled Magnus to the
top uncatchable tournament champion
Magnus Carlsen 8 points out of 11 and a
May
amazing epic performance